otro giro en la Guerra de Ucrania y otra
potencial escalada Ucrania ha condenado
las afirmaciones no fundamentadas de
Rusia de que quien podría utilizar la
llamada bomba sucia un dispositivo que
utiliza explosivos para esparcir
residuos radiactivos el presidente
ucraniano bolodimir selenski advirtió
que esto significa que Rusia sería la
que podría estar preparando un ataque de
este tipo si Rusia llama y dice que
Ucrania supuestamente está preparando
algo significa una cosa Rusia ya ha
preparado todo esto creo que ahora el
mundo debe reaccionar de la forma más
dura posible si Rusia ha preparado otra
escalada debe ver ahora que el mundo no
Se lo va a aguantar
una bomba sucia no tiene el efecto
devastador de una explosión nuclear pero
podría exponer amplias zonas a la
contaminación radiactiva en una
declaración conjunta los ministros de
asuntos exteriores de Francia Reino
Unido y Estados Unidos también
rechazaron las acusaciones de Rusia
nuestros países dejaron Claro que todos
rechazamos las acusaciones
transparentemente falsas de Rusia de que
Ucrania se está preparando para utilizar
una bomba sucia en su propio territorio
el mundo vería a través de cualquier
intento de utilizar este alegato Como un
pretexto para la escalada además
rechazamos cualquier Disculpa para una
escalada por parte de Rusia el ministro
de defensa ruso serge yoigo entregó las
declaraciones sobre la bomba sucia el
domingo durante las llamadas con sus
homólogos de Francia Turquía Reino Unido
y Estados Unidos pero
Moscú no ha aportado ninguna prueba que
respalde sus afirmaciones las
acusaciones rusas llegan tras una serie
de duras derrotas militares y mientras
las tropas ulcranianas continúan sus
operaciones de contraofensiva en el este
y el sur del país